muito obrigado
bobagem oi tanta coisa que ela falou
realmente eu me considero que gosta de
viajar era gostar da vida do campo e
gostou muito da tecnologia
vamos falar da desconexão com o campo
mas antes disso eu gostaria saber
quantos de vocês moura noite no campo ou
perto de camp cidades culturais
algum de vocês um
agora eu gostaria saber quantos de vocês
têm e seus pais ou a bolsa
morava em uma fazenda em campo roupa
muitos então talvez estão desconectados
hoje do campo mas estávamos muito
conectados no campo antes
esta palestra com começa com essa
desconexão
mas bah finalizar diferentemente
vamos dar uma prévia lição de geografia
muitos de vocês já ouviram falar de 8 do
ural estamos falando e o processo de
migração que eu conheço muitos são
migrantes quantas pessoas vão do campo
às cidades
vamos ver que isto é relevante e olhei
durante os anos 70 a maior parte da
migração ocorreu do campo as grandes
cidades estamos falando de rio de
janeiro estamos falando de sao paulo
pouco depois de décadas depois as
migrações foram ainda do campo à cidade
mas as cidades menores como indaiatuba
outro final melhor o conceito é ex do
urbano que quando a gente começa a sair
das cidades e vá para o campo
isso não acontece muito hoje mas eu
quero falar para vocês e dar talvez
alguns motivos porque isso vai começar a
acontecer
nesta palestra está orientá la para um
público alvo
eu quero conversar com vocês os milênios
os milênios
são todos vocês que nasceram em 1981
depois eu gostaria saber que nessa
obsessão por favor levanta a mão mais
50%
então esta palestra para vocês é o
convite que vou fazer também para vocês
o que os miller são eles estão que eles
querem se engajar
eles querem perto de ser ele tem muita
energia e uma coisa
as meninas conhecem tecnologia vive em
tecnologia você que está tirando foto aí
você millennium não mas para esse aí
outro milena ela traz
mas vocês conhecem tecnologia se conheça
das tecnologias modernas dos iphones
aplicativos coletividade e tudo isso a
internet das coisas vamos falar disso
daqui a pouco mas outra coisa é você
procura uma boa qualidade de vida
vocês querem morar se conectar e
interagir se divertir pesquisas falam
que muitos milênios querem ser pais e
dedicar seu tempo a ser bons pais e mais
uma coisa que super relevante
vocês querem mudar o mundo está
procurando causa estão procurando apoiar
como muitas das palestras que nós já
vemos ótimas
eu quero oferecer a vocês uma causa
importante para 2050
nós vamos ter novo épico assim cup de 80
pessoas pessoas aqui no mundo e como já
nós ouvimos em algumas outras palestras
não dá para continuar expandindo a terra
nós vamos ter que produzir mais mas
quando a mesma terra
nós queremos salvar poupar o mato
queremos ter parques queremos ter
o marco tudo isso então não conseguimos
continuar expandindo nossa terra como
que vamos fazer isso já está acontecendo
outra coisa continua a migração para as
cidades têm que produzir alimentos levar
lhes as idades
e outra coisa mais na meia crises ainda
com crises com que tudo isso o mundo
está cada dia melhor com melhor
qualidade de vida temos mais e mais
pessoas na meia em ano mais dinheiro e
eles vão procurar melhores alimentos
mais proteína é vi muita coisa
o que vamos fazer isso o brasil já
começou a se eu penso que o celeiro do
mundo começou quando esse plantio
direito conservando o solo a fertilidade
depois o brasil com seu clima tropical
um dos poucos países aonde você pensar a
safrinha depois botar gado você produz o
ano todo e isso não acontece na europa
não aconteceu nos estados unidos
aconteceu aqui neste país e agora pronto
também temos mais uma revolução que está
chegando e integração lavoura pecuária
floresta
alguém falou da sustentabilidade a
agricultura também está votando muito
foco na sustentabilidade ambiental e
você em galo tem graus têm florista todo
para produzir mais e mais sustentável
muito bem com a tecnologia estava se
movendo
mas isso tem algum efeito plano que tem
nos seus produtores hoje estão gerando
riquezas agricultura um dos motores da
economia brasileira estamos saindo da
crise
temos que ser muito otimista porque a
coisa está rolando cada vez melhor e e
isso em parte e por a tecnologia mas
olha não estamos falando de plantio
direito de safras
só nessas novas tecnologias da dois
milênios que vocês conhecem
parece que não o são
ao falar das novas tecnologias a
internet começou há 30 anos pouco uma
coisa se conectando as pessoas
depois o cuba quando você querer
procurar alguma coisa o tesouro a gula
que glee
agora você paga para o google o que for
depois disso nós temos é altos elétricos
depois o iphone eu quero ter tudo bem
aqui comigo calendário com ligações
mensagem tudo isso essas tecnologias dos
milênios que cid a queremos estar
contato com as famílias queremos estar
colaborando em facebook e está gerando a
nuvem o que eu queria falar pra vocês
que cada uma dessas tecnologias e também
um impacto cada vez maior na agricultura
com veículos mais sofisticados que tem
piloto automático que podem fazer mapas
de ter rendimento enfim com muita
tecnologia
você agora boa em um trator uma
colheitadeira para isso no avião com
tanta que ela tem
isso está mudando
não só a agricultura mas também como as
pessoas estão colaborando
acho que vocês podem imaginar que a
companhia vou mencionar aqui
quantos de vocês utiliza número é
conveniente está mudando a mobilidade é
o mais importante mais relevante que
antes nós temos um número limitado de
pessoas que trabalham e trabalham como
taxistas
agora qualquer de noite qualquer um de
nós pode ser em dinheiro e serviços o
que quero falar
e que essas tecnologias estão integrando
estão permitindo que todos nós podemos
participar das coisas está afetando as
viagens das casas aqui a educação a
saúde a agricultura será que ele cultura
está ficando atrás
se pela frente cada vez mais nós temos
segmentos tratores máquinas todos
conectados e porque isso é importante
porque quando nós estamos vindo como
vamos continuar produzindo para
alimentar esses 9,5 milhões de pessoas
olha aqui temos nossas máquinas
conectadas pessoas conectadas
o tema desta de tv que desce conexão é
mais a conexão
precisamos pessoas que escrevem
aplicativos para olhar como está a
acompanhar o crescimento das plantas
precisamos pessoas que têm capacidade
pessoal for e de conectividade para as
máquinas
precisamos pessoas que vão estar criando
sistemas de gerenciamento para as
grandes fazendas e também para os
fazendeiros pequenos
talvez vão precisar ainda mais ajudar
vocês
opa
vamos falar da qualidade de vida
eu não estou falando que as cidades são
ruins as idades nos juntar a nós
permitem compartilhar colaborar tudo o
que foi dito nas palestras anteriores e
nos permitiu sem por ver a mensagem os
trabalhos empresas tudo isso mas quando
eu estou olhando tanto carro ainda
marginal quanto tempo que está sendo
jogado no lixo que também seja não é
qualidade de vida que vocês querem saber
se a qualidade está muito mais avançada
vocês vão ter a calma para aproveitar
todo esse tempo e beber uma cerveja com
seus amigos
o caminhar com seus filhos bater um papo
ler o livro olhar a paisagem o que for
que esta pergunta onde é parece que a
vida um pouco mais tranquila
o tempo vai um pouco mais devagar e
finalmente a vida mais longa porque
dinheiro e gastar você ganha
é isso vai embora e não volta
o brasil tem um futuro grande brasil vai
alimentar o mundo
mas o convite é para aqui vocês que
estão interessados em desenvolver
tecnologias pelo terceiro em gel e tudo
isso trabalhar porque nossos produtores
- sempre conhecer as tecnologias como
vocês nem sempre têm a inovação a
iniciativa a criatividade
então eu acho que eles precisam da ajuda
de vocês todos vocês que levantar a sua
mão ea cabeça se entende ou menos né
vamos para o campo eu comecei a falar
falando com a desconexão do campo
falamos de migração na minha lição de
geografia para nossas tecnologias
falamos dos milênios que estão tentando
mudar o mundo
falamos também da cidade
então o que eu gostaria s para finalizar
está a palestra o final de outro jeito
vamos falar de conexão com o campo e
vamos falar num lugar aonde a gente pode
fazer uma diferença
criar os filhos e mudar o mundo muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]